[Music]
all I have to say is don't cross you
just go in it okay
new comer eat played by Tiffani Heinz is
shaking things up and Devils nation how
shocking was it for you when you read
that script and saw how you were gonna
be not so sweet this season when I read
it I was like oh that's you know that's
really cool and then I watched all three
seasons and I'm like oh that's who I am
you know and just to see how it evolved
I thought it was spicy I loved her I'm
Olivia and chases daughter Wow
but Olivia and chase had a kid no one
knew about can she be trusted at this
point knowing her family named in her
history and her revengeful spirit it
seems if her mom is Olivia Vincent I
don't think so
stay outta Bebe's way stay out of her
way she's a bulldozer so look out Eve
has a lineage that you cannot brush off
you need to take her seriously but who
she's coming for they don't play so it's
gonna be interesting to see how she's
gonna try and get her way trying to stay
out of trouble do you think I'm in
trouble I think a lot of people are
gonna pay attention to her characters
your imagination runs wild it she gets
but this president starts to mingle and
they started to talk in and what happens
is right so there's so much there's so
much to reveal in season 4 you're
clearly a great guy when I look forward
to working with the first big reveal
naive could be responsible for this is
this Pete Davenport
he died on impact
his blood alcohol was 0.28 it was dree
John Dean has been with us since day one
and to pull a drawer out and have coach
Pete on a slab is rough so I don't
really know if you're gonna be like and
here's a cake like it's not really that
kind of vibe Pete has always been a
stabilizing force and so taking away
that stability and how it affects
Derrick how it affects Lionel how it
affects Devils arena you've come for the
juicy story and this is something that
really launches a lot of ships I think
people are gonna be very very excited to
see Dean Cain's character this season
and what's to come of him and where it
takes him and and what happens you know
how the effect of it is Pete Davenport
bonded with Dean since the first day
like shooting baskets out on the court
these always been and will continue to
be you know somebody that's always a
good person before advise me the
Superman
[Music]
recall I said our goodbyes and told her
how much we appreciate him he was like
all right I'm hopping on a plane to
Spain gonna keep going to DC I trusted
you theory you married my daughter we
were talking about ahsha and Elena I've
been dealing with Yelena
she's not my problem one area I see you
kind of dabbling in is possibly a love
interest with London see Ana's character
is that gonna be a slow burn or more of
a friendship since you both are kind of
healing in a few areas
Derek in London has some coming out
because they're both coming through
things and I think typically that's you
know that's what happens when you're
going things you you you you seek the
counsel or like the comfort of somebody
that's experienced something similar
yeah but as far as whatever it is you
know we'll definitely find out but if
it's anything like it the floor it's
probably gonna be it's either gonna pop
up on you whatever it is are is gonna be
a slow reveal go to grab opportunities
when you can Derek Lowe
[Music]